anyway we're getting into the speed
round time fill in the blank
version whichever team signs cam newton
is getting what peter
someone who wants to shove it up a lot
of people's rear ends
i don't think i could say that better
myself and he's especially motivated to
prove that stupid kid wrong who was
telling him
uh you're about to be poor stealers
the steelers are blank for trying to
make it work with big ben
probably smart because he gives them the
best option to win
10 games in 2021 yeah i think foolish
because i think they're both going to
regret this come november or december
it's time to move on
they're going to move on next year just
go ahead and move on this year and be
done with it whichever team gets
signs jj watt is getting what peter
a player who will have a very good
season
but only if he has good players around
him
and i'll add to that someone who will
sell a lot of jerseys
a lot of tickets and create a lot of
excitement from a business standpoint
and be a great member of
whatever community he joins for 2021 and
beyond
you are blank by jj watts
cryptic tweets including but not limited
to
mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
cell
mystified but
kind of happy that he is throwing crumbs
out on the trail
for nin compost like me to try to figure
out
i'll tell you that's more i love this
one about now
yeah and it's i it was all it reminded
me of one of your haikus
he he it it almost
the most intriguing aspect of a 17-game
schedule will be
what
match-ups that will happen
more often than they should
between teams that we need to see
play each other more often
that's the key those extra games those
extra games that 17th game is going to
match teams
inner conference based on where they
finished in their division on a rotating
basis but we're going to have more ones
against ones we're gonna have
more opportunities to see you know
saints
and chiefs uh than we otherwise would if
they both finish first in their division
also
nine home games eight road games peter i
thought that what they would do is have
just a full week of of uh neutral site
games
but they're not going to be ready for 16
neutral site games so there's going to
be teams that have more home games than
road games and you have to wonder
whether or not that creates just a
little bit of a competitive imbalance if
some teams have nine now mike so
the way they're gonna have to do it is
they're gonna have to have
one side if it's afc nfc they're gonna
have to have
all of the afc teams at home one year
and then
all the afc teams that on the road the
next year
because there's no way you can say to
the new york giants for instance
oh by the way you got nine home games
this year in dallas
you have eight it's just from a
competitive advantage
it's just unfair so that that extra game
that extra inner conference game
one year it's all nfc home teams one
year it's all afc home teams that's how
you avoid
divisions having some teams with eight
and some teams right nine that's an
excellent point and one last thing too
the record book is going to get screwed
up and i remember back in the late 70s
when they went from 14 to 16. nobody
ever said
boo about records being easier to to
supersede
but you know you talked previously about
a 6 000 yard pass or with 17 games it's
gonna happen
well but i think the difference is in
1978
the nfl was covered in a sane fashion
by people who covered the nfl for six
months a year
and then uncovered college basketball
for baseball
now you have each city
having nine beat riders for the whole
season
and and the off season too that's why
we've gotten to the insane part of our
lives
which is having a hey look look at you
you got a two-hour show it's whatever
february 28 and 6
come on it's all insane
if by insane you mean we are all
gainfully employed
then i agree with you it's supply and
demand
the consumer demands it and we supply it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports